il voulait parler au ministre vous allez
au ministère de la taille le siège du
mouvement des citoyens le mouvement de
jean pierre chevènement investit
aujourd'hui par une centaine de
sans-papiers de saint bernard
une façon de rappeler leur colère et
leur impatience
malgré la circulaire de régularisation
du ministre dix-huit mois après la lutte
nous avons aujourd'hui sans personne
d'entre nous qui attend plusieurs la
régularisation
la politique n'a jamais été les papiers
pour tous par conséquent si c'est le
slogan qui est le vôtre
je dois dire et même sous la pression
est à présent que beaucoup d'entre vous
ce slogan ne peut pas être satisfait en
milieu d'après-midi les sans papiers ont
été évacués par les forces de l'ordre
il attend désormais une réponse du
ministère de l'intérieur